zum wohle zum wurde ich hätte das jetzt
da aber sie können auch das ja furchtbar
da wird gerne mit ihnen über ihre
gefühle sprechen
lauterbach hallo schön sie zu sehen
schön sie zu sehen
eine fliege die erste assoziation für
frauen bei fliege ist natürlich immer
chippendales diese männliche stripper
bande ich werde sie bitten sich trotzdem
nicht auszuziehen
da kann sorge dass ich gar nicht sogar
noch jemand sage ich ihnen garantieren
wir machen heute anti kater getränke
wann haben sie das letzte mal in
schlimmen karte es noch gar nicht so
lange her nach den letzten wahlen also
haben wir uns trost gespendet dann
fangen wir jetzt mal an mit kokoswasser
kokoswasser fällt mir natürlich jetzt im
ganz schnellen kopf spontan ein kokon
sie wollen jetzt ja die coco machen
nicht mehr die groko was hat es damit
auf sich
naja damit wollen wir wesentlichen also
ein bisschen mehr abstand mit zur cdu
haben also werden das zusammenarbeiten
aber das wichtigste noch durchbekommen
so ein bisschen fernbeziehung stylen
oder ihrer offenen beziehung vielleicht
halb offen hat offen also war tut was er
will unter anderem muss sich danach
richten wir machen heute einen kokos
kurkuma bananen getränk wie viele
hirnzellen tötete und vollrausch schwer
zu sagen da geht schon was verloren
das ist also das ist also da habe ich so
manch ein opfergang hinter mir was
halten sie von diesem trend mit wodka
tampons dass man es direkt über die
schleimhäute aufnimmt und somit
eigentlich den magen schon da habe ich
komplett blank davon rät zum letzten mal
so wie diese verköstigung habe ich noch
nicht gesehen sagt will ich gar nicht
erst auf wodka einläufe eingehen ein
witziger es ist also wie gesagt das
sprengt man wissen aber sie wollen doch
in berlin sie müssen doch wissen wie man
party macht ja wenn ich zu einer party
also sehr kommentar habe ich jetzt zum
sterben kälber oder was ist da da da wo
das praktiziert wird
dort gehört haben und so kritisch keine
enthaltungen die zeit ist leider vorbei
wenn sie gut krankenversichert
privatmann super
symbole zu holen ich hätte das jetzt da
eine aber sie können das ja furchtbar
ja ich würde gerne mit ihnen über ihre
gefühle sprechen was ich müsste ich tun
dass sie jetzt wein und noch mehr von
dem trinken wenn sie jetzt definitiv
ankündigen würden das im februar
neuwahlen hätten dann würde ich hier in
den satz zu weinen
sie haben sehr subtilen humor man möchte
fast schon sagen sie am tumor aber sie
haben sehr sehr subtil
danke danke für das ist gut ist nicht so
haut drauf wie die restlichen leute in
der comedy szene
dann kommen wir zum zweiten anti kater
drink an dieser stelle vielleicht mal
ein dankeschön an den alkohol ohne
diesen ja ein anti kater drin gar nicht
möglich wäre
keine frage ist der ursprung was denken
sie welche partei hat die meisten
alkoholika unter ihren mitgliedern die
csu und index jahr heftig zwischen den
zweien wird seinen kopf an kopf rennen
geben ok sehr gut dann kommen wir zum
zweiten getränk auch hier wieder
kokoswasser jetzt kommt der party laut
aber nennt man sie eigentlich immer
professor doktor lauterbach oder kann
man sie auch herr lauterbach alles
erlaubt karl carlos charles carlo janka
es schwer sie nur noch chaos professor
carlo das ist wirklich mal vielen dank
stimmt auch so ein bisschen jetzt selber
mögen sie sellerie
naja ich glaube wir müssen uns noch
klein sie wollen die bürgerversicherung
durchsetzen ich finde bürgerversicherung
das klingt so logisch ich verstehe nicht
mal warum es das nicht schon lange gibt
wo ist der haken
das heißt dann wird nur so behandelt wie
jetzt medizinisch notwendig ist nicht
nicht danach also wie viel gewinn ich
mit den patienten machen kann aber auf
der anderen seite wird die private
versicherung auch so teuer dass die
älteren privatversicherten ja nachher
wie bittsteller durch system laufen und
mit schwarz bittsteller nicht page also
patches so war es auch nur bittsteller
die bittsteller die bettler ich würde es
nicht als heute war dass politiker nicht
sagen dürfen aber hier sind sie ja
mensch ja antworte ich kann aber nicht
ganz aus der rolle fallen sonst hätte
ich gesagt das war's aber sage ich nicht
ganz ja sagen ja sie können sagte x
sowie privat versicherten die nachher
die prämie nicht mehr bezahlen können
und daher in altersarmut geraten und zum
teil von krediten die
krankenhausrechnung bezahlen das sind
arme menschen man könnte auch sagen arme
sau wenn sie sagen kann man so sagen ja
das weiß ich dass sie sich nicht dreckig
machen
schön dass sie so gut mitmachen
sie wissen ja wie man sagt jetzt noch
ratings ganz gut
krass ist nicht für mich schlimmer als
der karte fürs dritte getränk haben wir
uns einen globalen mix ausgedacht und
zwar nehmen wir dafür eine karte
spezialität aus jedem land also hoffe
dass das jetzt besser wird der zweite
trinkt war grauenhaft und ich kann mir
kaum vorstellen dass nach unten noch
spielraum besteht
hab ich mich wenn ich ja haben sie sich
vertan kaffee ein rollmops machen
dank nicht mir ginseng aus china schon
besser genau sieht aus wie diese
fingernägel im guinness world record es
ist also ganz lange fingernägel hat ich
nehme jetzt diesen rollmops sie müssen
einen rollmops mit speisen dann wissen
wir das mal wo sind sie gerade bei
breaking bad
ich habe die sendung durch aber alle
waren glaube ich sechs staffeln der ja
geschaut
das wurde am schluss den drachen so zimt
oder und dann das königshaus übernimmt
das war es ist das muss games gewählt
haben sie das auch jetzt schon nicht so
fendt ist es scheine ich gesagt dass ich
lieber zu hektik kann sie epilepsie nähe
habe ich nicht noch nicht
es ist ein party becherwerfer becher und
guckt das mal dann erstmals zum wohl
dann würde ich sagen dass top mittel
also wir müssen hier nachher noch weiter
drehen bitte nicht gerade kurzen das
beste mittel gegen kater ist natürlich
immer noch einfach weiterlaufen ich das
jetzt kommen wir zur sache ja wohl auf
was stoßen
die nach dem gelungenen karte ja das ist
wahr das ist das was wir den zuschauern
empfehlen können glaube ich ist mein
eindruck ist ja klar
super danke schön wäre besser
[Musik]